foreign
I have heard a lot about excess deaths
right stevanovic the analysis uses a
five-year rolling average
understanding that this is meant to
smooth out the signal from the noise is
five years really the best time frame do
we see similar excesses when longer time
frames are utilized with 10 20 Etc years
give different results
this is an interesting question I
haven't thought
enough about exactly what is being done
this is this is a question that is new
to me I haven't given this any thought
before
um
I guess I'd like to see it I'd like
I was gonna say I'd like to see it done
but I'd like to know first what I think
and I'm not sure yet what I think
um I think for this set of questions you
are inherently looking for a short time
scale and that
the question of time scale is always
going to be
um
it is always going to be heavily
affected by
what process you are interested in
discovering its presence or absence so I
do think short time scales you have to
do it on that because let's say that
we're looking for I mean what we're
really looking for is
excess deaths as a result of covid alone
and then using that
to find excess deaths that are the
result of covid Plus
uh the so-called vaccines
and you have
let's put it this way if you're looking
for the signal of the vaccines
the comparison has a built-in
conservatism which is good the chances
that you will see a phantom that isn't
there are reduced because
um the because to the extent that
certain people were very vulnerable to
covid many of them were lost or became
immune because they got it and survived
it or became somewhat immune
and so to the extent you see excess
deaths in 2021 that you didn't see in
2020 it implies something about our
remedies yeah but I mean this five-year
rolling average thing I'm just not sure
exactly what is being done so I mean I
feel like this is a statistical question
and neither you nor I I think from what
you just said know exactly what is being
done the five-year rolling average
suggests that something is being done
mathematically that I'm not totally
clear on
and you know one of the things that is
true is that we effectively have three
moments in time
uh that we are interested in comparing
to one another and one of them you know
is 2019 and earlier and one of them is
just 2020 and really you know just three
quarters of 2020 really which is Coveted
but no vaccines and one is 2021 going
forward and because that middle period
which is
um yes code but no vaccines no coveted
vaccines is so short I think therefore
you want
um if it's a rolling average you want
that that that unit to be as short as
possible as well but
I I have to know exactly what is being
done
yeah I mean I would
one of my favorite people on topics of
uh covet hazard
is John Campbell and the reason that I
say that he's one of my favorites is
that he has been
in my opinion if you're trying to figure
out what's going on
more careful than necessary because
aired in the direction of being careful
while not being the least bit cowardly
with respect to talking about what he
was seeing yep um the one place
uh that he is
uh
he did uh check out his last video on
excess deaths or recent video on excess
deaths he goes through the logic of it
very carefully he does
establish that there's a very clear
signal he talks about all of the
possibilities that he can come up with
for explanations save one which he says
look I'm forbidden to talk about this
one because of YouTube Community
guidelines which leaves you to connect
the dots
um you know and I wish he hadn't had to
do that but I understand why he did but
anyway he's been so careful about these
analyzes that I think you'll be struck
um by what he does now the work wasn't
his he's reviewing work that was done by
somebody else
so it's conceivable that he would have
chosen a different uh time period but I
think the answer is these things aren't
heavily sensitive
to you know the difference between a
five-year or a six year right it might
be a difference between you know a five
year and a ten year shows a substantial
uh change in the direction of noise
because it includes a period that is
less comparable right the number of
things that is different over 10 years
um so anyway I think the point is the
pattern is so clear that one doesn't
need to worry terribly much about
whether that's exactly the right period
over which to study it
right but you I mean if if a 10 or 20
year Rolling average would uh reveal
less pattern and you know you really
think that the pattern is so clear you
should put it to that analysis and then
be able to say see I went conservative
here like I you know this this would be
less likely to reveal pattern and it
still does
well but I don't think that's how it
works because
the problem of what factor is captured
in a 20-year rolling average that would
be absent from a five means that it's
not inherently conservative it's noisy
and high variance
um so you might augment a pattern beyond
what it actually is you might erase a
pattern that actually is and the the
thing that we can say is that the period
of time that is most similar to the one
we live in is the one directly prior to
it yep
[Music]